[Music]
hey everybody my name is chef Marcus
Samuelsson and I'm the Pastis executive
chef in residence I'm Alexis and I'm the
food specialist at tasty I'm Alex I'm
from Northern California and I'm a tasty
producer Claudette Zepeda Wilkins from
San Diego executive chef partner at el
ha Devine restaurant what's up I'm JJ
Johnson I'm a chef and cookbook author
based here in New York City
my name is Ken Sean Coyle I'm the
creator of a food blog and author of
recently published cookbook spice spice
baby hi I'm Maria I'm a tasty producer
I'm from Japan and I went to culinary
school in New York hey yo I'm born
Breland I'm from Raleigh North Carolina
and I'm a tasty producer one of the
things that I love about takes the
initiative is we can introduce new
talent and be more inclusive and diverse
what I think Tastee has really hit the
nail on the head in that the show's
represent how we eat today in this world
when I think about the reach that tasty
has its wild we really kind of cover a
huge part of different cuisines food has
always been so important to me I mean I
fully blame my mother and making me a
real food snob I've always loved cooking
in the kitchen it was an integral part
of my childhood cooking has always been
in my DNA I've always been cooking with
my grandmother since the age of about 5
so because I didn't go to culinary
school I feel like I'm able to connect
with our audience who just loves food
and loves cooking themselves you don't
have to be classically trained to enjoy
food and love cooking I always loved
playing around with food my aunt had a
restaurant my entire childhood and when
I cut out so I spent my entire youth in
her restaurant
I grew up ever since I could walk
cooking with my mom and my grandma in
the kitchen growing up in India spices
were everywhere and we kind of took them
for granted it was only when I moved to
the US I realized wow not everyone is
that well versed with spices I'm very
fortunate as
roll different backgrounds Ethiopian
Scandinavians living in Harlem I've been
fortunate enough to really have windows
into so many different cultures I think
the tasty talent from my understanding
or what I've seen it was like oh wow
it's really truly hitting all demos and
food is demographics of the world I'm
excited to be able to bring Mexican
flavors that I grew up eating and that
are part of my story to your home I mean
as a chef you're like I want my recipe
on tasty is about to break the internet
and it's so fun that people are actually
making this you know so many people
message and say like oh this really
helped me or a friend will say how do I
make rice and I just send them the link
it's really really gratifying I'm super
excited to have tasty give me the direct
link to you guys Cheers Bon Appetit big
you
you